bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france en ligne alors
c'est vrai que la vaccination
obligatoire est un serpent de mer qui
revient incessamment depuis l'ouverture
de la vaccination en france
est ce que votre position par rapport à
ce débat d'abord je suivrai que la
vaccination des soignants est une
exigence éthique et la protection des
patients est un devoir profiter d'un de
boer professionnels pour justement pour
les médecins comme tous les autres
soignants la vaccination diminue
considérablement les chambres de
transmission et qui pour cette raison
que j'appelle tous les soignants à la
prise de conscience de l'importance de
se faire vacciner au profit des
personnes vulnérables est vrai par
contre rendre obligatoire tout de suite
pour moi je ne suis pas favorable je
compte d'abord attendre en plus tôt à il
faut plutôt convaincre les soignants
entré en discussions avec eux justement
les comprendre justement l'importance de
ce vaccin
et puis oui d'ici là au mois d'août
forme en le rendant obligatoire sont
arrive à convaincre les soignants pour
justement éviter une quatrième bague je
le rappelle vous êtes directeur d'un
ehpad comment vous expliquer ce chiffre
moins de 60% des personnels soignants
n'est pas de son maxi mais parce que je
pense que certains directeurs n'ont pas
pu car preuve de pédagogie et n'ont pas
su du coup convaincre les derniers
soignants réticents à la vaccination je
pense qu'ils ont manqué de pédagogie
et puis je pense qu'un bus de campagne
matif sur la vaccination étaient pour
cette raison que le taux est extrêmement
bas comment d'ailleurs se portent les
ehpad aujourd'hui face à la crise du
côté de 19 bat pour le moment justement
grâce à la vaccination des résidents qui
on le rappelle le quasiment vacciner
c'est à dire nous dormons plus de cas de
contamination au sein des ehpad
il ya un taux de mortalité qui est au
plus bas et évidemment nous ne
connaissons plus de clusters depuis je
vais dire de moi est une bonne chose et
c'est pour cette raison que j'invite
tous les soignants à se faire vacciner
comme temps peut vraiment avoir le
retour à la vie normale dans les ehpad
maintenant dans notre ehpad en tout cas
qui est sûr et certain c'est que les
familles peuvent venir visiter en
chambre peuvent manger avec eux donc
vraiment la seule chose qui reste et le
respect
la dimension locale et le port du mac
en tout cas les déclarations d'olivier
vermont pas passée inaperçue pourquoi
cibler uniquement les les soignants des
ehpad puisque les soignants des ehpad
justement sont au contact des personnes
fragiles c'est qu'il a indiqué sur ou
d'antennes de vos confrères
donc c'est pour cette raison qu'il
incite vivement mais t'es tu n'es pas
que en maison de retraite il ya aussi
sûrement en service de réanimation en
table et d'oncologie honte de mon logis
en fait si vraiment c'est tous les
soignants qui s'occupe des personnes
vulnérables et on sait très bien que les
personnes fragiles ont payé un lourd
tribut durant la crise sanitaire
et comme la crise est loin d'être finie
je dirais donc c'est pour cette raison
que nous devons assurer au moins une
protection
lorsqu'on prodiguent des soins les gars
2 et s'agissant parce que c'est lié la 2
s'agissant de la vaccination des
résidents qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous
dire et bâle nous avons les rhénans qui
tomba qui n'a à peu près à hauteur de 99
% qui est très bien nous avons de
nouveaux résidants qui rentre dans les
maisons de retraite donc bien évidemment
nous avons commandé les bacs d'un
puisque c'est vrai que l'art est nous
avait plus délivrés depuis un mois et
demi donc on devait les amener dans 20
centres de vaccination qui était pas
parfois je dire pâtit l'aider parce que
j'allais prévoir un train un moyen de
logistique
bon maintenant c'est plus facile
maintenant les deux seront à nouveau des
libres et pour les nouveaux résidents et
c'est une bonne chose c'est à dire que
voilà on souhaite vraiment qu'il ya
peut-être couverture à 100%
puisqu'on ne veut plus vivre ce moment
où on a dû confiner les personnes âgées
parce que tu étais extrêmement compliqué
pour eux est très difficile
alors expliquez nous pourquoi la
vaccination des résidents puisqu'on est
au dessus de 90 % ne suffit pas et
puisque aura suffit là je vais dire
avait vu que le retour à la normale dans
les ehpad a été fait depuis deux mois et
donc et grâce à la vaccination des
résidents qu'on a pu permettre ce retour
donc mais c'est vrai que pour vraiment
avoir jédir l'écho l'ensemble de
l'écosystème jeudi rva qu'une et est une
bonne chose et des tie bi tra toute
contamination
et ce qui me fait peur je vous préviens
je vous cache pas que les variants
indien britannique et c'est pour cette
raison que nous incitons et nous avions
vraiment tous les soins de viande hachée
vacciner mais encore une fois si les
soignants ne veulent pas de faire
vacciner bien évidemment on respectera
ce choix je dis ah bon c'est pour cela
que la question de rendre obligatoire
bon moi je suis plutôt dans la pédagogie
puis même faudra toute façon si un jour
elle est obligatoire
draw s'est accompagnée d'une manière
pédagogique je ne suis pas pour
reprendre des fonctions de licenciement
de mises à pied
vata hors de question moi je pense que
les soignants comprendront bientôt j'ai
prenant conscience de l'importance faire
vacciner encore une fois au profit des
personnes vulnérables pour éviter une
quatrième vague de vaccination
obligatoire au sein des ehpad est ce que
ça va avoir un impact logistiques
importants non puisque maintenant c'est
très fatigant nous avons monté vrai que
dans l'est des pâtés plutôt le vaccin
fighter mais on peut bien évidemment
pour les soignants avoir d'autres
acteurs avec une seule injection donc au
niveau logistique n'ya même plus de même
problème qu'on a connu en janvier
et vous avez vous réclamez une
concertation avec olivier ferrand
est ce que vous avez reçu une réponse je
n'ai pas eu pris contact avec le
ministre de la santé au leader en et je
pense que c'est à 8 de mener en
concertation
et d'expliquer la raison aux soignants
en disant voilà nous allons en
obligatoires peut-être en septembre
parce qu'on nous voulons éviter une
quatrième vague
nous allons voir comment ça se passe là
parce que le déconfinement est annoncée
dès demain voir comment justement là
dire le virus circule et encore une fois
on veut éviter une quatrième bague était
serait dommage que certains soignants
puisse attraper le virus sur le lieu de
travail voyez donc il faut tout faire
pour éviter cela il ya encore une fois
n'est pas c'était un geste de solidarité
je veux dire au profit des personnes
vulnérables au profit des personnes
d'âgés merci beaucoup à vous danny
foster
je rappelle que vous êtes directeur a
dans les pattes dans l'eure et loir